welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn Wilkes your host and our guest
is Alex Deb's
an associate professor of political
science and a research fellow at the
Macmillan Center his work focuses on the
causes of war nuclear proliferation and
democratization and his work has been
featured in numerous scholarly
publications today we'll talk with
Professor Debs
about the new book he co-wrote with Nuno
Montero titled nuclear politics the
strategic causes of proliferation
welcome professor Deb's good to be with
you well your book comes at the perfect
time especially with all of the news
about North Korea and Iran so let's get
right down to it tell us about your book
well what the book does is it oh it
looks at the history of nuclear
proliferation and considers the causes
of proliferation why our state's
interested in acquiring a nuclear weapon
and which states are successful in this
endeavor and so the book offers a theory
of the causes of proliferation and
reviews the diplomatic history between
the states that are considering
acquiring nuclear weapons and other
concerned States enemies and allies
alike okay and what led you to write the
book well if we look at other
explanations of nuclear proliferation
intuitively the security angle would be
the most compelling nuclear weapons are
after all weapons but people who have
taken that approach have only looked at
the interests of states that want to
acquire nuclear weapons and that's led
to an over prediction of proliferation
too many states would be interested in
getting them and too few get them and so
we were interested in understanding how
we can solve that puzzle and how we can
understand which states are successful
in acquiring nuclear weapons and in the
process of doing the research we amassed
a lot of information much of it is
available digitally
with for example the diplomatic archives
of the Foreign Relations of the United
States being available online and it
became clear to us that this needed to
be in the form of a book as opposed to
small articles okay and and how did you
do the research for it in addition to
what you just said yeah so we did the
research it was a dialogue between
theory and evidence and so we try to
break down the problem into small parts
so first looking at relations between
potential proliferators and their
enemies and understanding when states
are successful at getting weapons and
then adding a third another dimension
which is the role of allies in many
cases for example the u.s. is involved
in many security commitments and some
states even though they have security
commitments from the US have at various
points consider getting nuclear weapons
but once we have the baseline of states
without security allies we can
understand the effect of alliances and
that's how we broke down the theoretical
problem and in terms of the evidence as
I said there's a lot that's available
both digital digitally from the web but
also from archives and secondary sources
and so we analyze that data to try to
see what were States leaders thinking in
the pros and cons of getting nuclear
weapons and and then went back to the
blackboard and revised the theory
accordingly okay and despite what we
hear in the news today particularly
about North Korea not very many
countries have nuclear weapons why is
that well that's one of the puzzles that
motivated our theory and we seem to be
very concerned about proliferation but
that's one of the paradoxes of
proliferation that not many countries
have nuclear weapons so should we worry
about it should we not worry about it
they don't have them but do they want
them some definitely want them and
others probably not so much right so I
mean if we look back we're currently
worried about North Korea which has
proven its capability of having nuclear
weapons but if we rerun a few years back
before that it was Iran before that it
was Iraq so there were states that
expressed an interest in getting nuclear
weapons and often we talk of nuclear
weapons as the weapons of the
week so if a state would lose a
conventional war it would greatly
benefit from acquiring nuclear weapons
and so there is documented evidence of
state leaders being interested in
getting nuclear weapons but very few are
actually successful in acquiring them
and why is that so for us it's that
there are unique circumstances where a
state is both interested in getting
nuclear weapons and able to get them
so in short nuclear weapons or weapons
of the weak but that we can't get them
so the same reason that a state but why
can't they get them because of the
actions of other states around them the
enemies and the allies so if we it would
seem to me that because it's information
that already existed and is out there
it's so very difficult to figure out how
to build a nuclear weapon
hmm well so there's a technological
aspect so you need to clear certain
hurdles in rich in uranium having the
delivery capabilities and all these
technical problems and now certainly
that will mean that certain states that
otherwise would have their security
needs met by an alliance may say this
would be too costly and I won't consider
it but there are many states that do
consider it they do consider there to be
a significant security benefit but in
that case they can be either coerced or
reassured by allies that they actually
don't need nuclear weapons so if we look
at States for example like the Soviet
Union the Soviet Union had a clear
security need but it was able to acquire
nuclear weapons because the u.s.
preventive war plans that that
Washington was considering were not
workable the cost would have been too
high whereas you have weaker states like
Iran Iraq and Syria thought at very
responsive having nuclear weapons but
they were unable to reach to include
that threshold and so a state needs to
be strong enough that it can withstand
pressures by other state and and and get
me - when you say strong enough what do
you mean by that so here in terms of the
measures we're looking at conventional
capabilities so when we look at
conventional capabilities there's
various measures that are being used but
you can look at manpower the size of the
armament size of the military
and so states that have otherwise a very
small military may feel that if there is
a security need getting nuclear weapons
could be their trump card but by the
same token if they're relatively weak
and their enemies have more manpower
military power these enemies are more
successful at using coercive threats and
and preventing those states from getting
nuclear weapons okay except in the case
of North Korea for instance so let's
talk about that a little bit yes you
know in fact give can you give the
trajectory of North Korean and how it's
come to now have a nuclear weapon yes so
North Korea has a clear security needs
the Korean War in 1953 ended with an
armistice not a peace treaty and so
technically North Korea is still at war
with the United States during the Cold
War North Korea had an alliance with the
Soviet Union and China two states that
provided assistance during the Korean
War especially the Chinese but North
Korea came to doubt the reliability of
the of these alliances and in the 80s
both the Soviet Union and China wanted
to improve their relations with South
Korea and so and so for North Korea it
made sense for them to have their own
deterrent and also looking at their
trajectory both economically and
militarily
the South Koreans were growing relative
to the North Koreans and so it made
sense to have this ultimate trump card
so you can see a clear security need for
having nuclear weapons but they also had
the opportunity to have nuclear weapons
and this is in part because of accidents
of geography so Seoul is very close to
the North Korean border only 30 miles or
so from the border and that's meant that
any preventive war plans that the
Americans and the South Koreans
considered were not very workable it
would have led to very high casualties
in South Korea even with North Korean
conventional response and so Bill
Clinton considered preventive war plans
and tabled them the United States came
to an agreed framework with North Korea
where North Korea would freeze its
program in exchange for economic
inducements but in the late 90s and
early 2000s the US was worried that
North Korea was not following through on
its commitments and the North Koreans
were worried that the Americans were not
quick enough in providing the incentives
that they had promised and so in the
Bush administration that george w bush
administration the agreed framework fell
apart North Korea withdrew from the NPT
and made its first test into that 2006
and its second in 2009 okay so when we
look at North Korea basically the last
few decades have been a family-run
country yes and it seems to me contrary
to them not necessarily wanting
protection but wanting to to weld to
wield power over the rest of the world
by developing a nuclear weapon mm-hmm
how does that fit into your strategy
well I think so there's I mentioned that
the the perspective we follow is one of
security so as a state worried about its
security would there be an advantage in
having new nuclear weapons other
perspectives are focused on this
argument that's described as one of
prestige so for example states like
France had a certain perception of their
role in the world and having nuclear
weapons was an argument to pursue those
interests I have yet to find a state
that's not interested in prestige so so
any state would be interested in
prestige and so for us even though these
arguments and these perspective might be
useful what we wanted to do is restrict
ourselves to the security dimension and
see how much of the variation we could
explain in empirical patterns okay so
how many countries actually do have
nuclear weapons we're looking at nine
current nuclear powers the US Russia
England France China India Pakistan
Israel and North Korea very few actually
and and how many actually would want
them North Korea where does Iran fall so
Iran has had a nuclear program but now
has come to an agreement to freeze its
it's its capabilities and so
you could think there is an interest the
US intelligence services have all
concluded that the leadership has never
made a decision to acquire nuclear
weapons but obviously other states are
skeptical and so so there's an there's a
latent capability in Iran so ultimately
in your book what do you conclude so
what we conclude is to best understand
proliferation we need to think about the
security dimensions but not just looking
at states interested in getting nuclear
weapons but like looking at their
relationship with other states
potentially concerned so enemies and
allies and so if we only look at
relationship between enemies US nuclear
weapons or weapons of the weak but that
we can't get them so you need to have
enough power enough conventional power
to withstand pressures of your enemies
and acquire nuclear weapons so a state
like the Soviet Union was able to get
nuclear weapons but states like Iran
Iran Iraq and Syria have not been able
to now once we know this we can look at
the effect of alliances and here allies
can play two roles they can reassure
potential proliferators and they can
also coerce them and reminding them that
they shouldn't try to acquire nuclear
weapons
and so we can understand also how these
two tools are effective if you're
looking at relatively strong potential
proliferators assurances might be
sufficient to prevent them from getting
nuclear weapons and if you're looking at
relatively weak potential proliferators
then here a more coercive approach could
be successful reminding the ally that
without for example the u.s. security
guarantees these states would be too
vulnerable and they wouldn't be able to
acquire nuclear weapons okay I'm going
to put you on the spot here for a minute
and ask you what do you think the United
States could have done better or should
be doing to lessen the impact or the
situation that is going on with North
North Korea right now well I think as I
mentioned before the North Korean
situation is particularly tricky because
there is no good military option and
even folks within the Trump
administration
I've admitted as much by saying if we
look at the plans even with their
conventional capabilities they could
inflict very severe damage on our allies
and our troops stationed in the region
and so I think it is concerning to see
the administration escalating rhetoric
when in fact the the military options
are not very good so I think we might
look back and say in general the US has
been relatively good at preventing
proliferation there are some situations
where it's very hard to do it but by
escalating the risks and maybe running
the risk of drawing a wedge between the
US and its allies in the region that
could lead to further proliferation so
if South Korea and Japan come to doubt
our security guarantees they may decide
at some point that they are-- they need
their own deterrent and the u.s.
experience so far in the region there
has been one of success of reassuring
these allies that the US would be there
and would be a responsible player in
that region all right well it will be
interesting to see how it plays out and
the weeks ahead thank you so much for
being here with us today and sharing
some of your work thank you for more
information about Professor Deb's and
his research please visit our website at
macmillan report yale.edu be sure to
join us again for another episode of the
Macmillan report made possible through
funding from the Whitney and Betty
Macmillan Center for International and
area studies at Yale
[Music]